certains le font par choix d'autres par
nécessité allez au centre-ville en
voiture et trouver une case de
stationnement c'est souvent le parcours
du combattant
on avait des moyens de transport à
l'extérieur de Montréal qui pourrait
nous rendre jusqu'ici facilement aussi
ce sera encore mieux quand c'est pas un
tournage c'est des bixies c'est plein
d'affaires finalement c'est pas fait
pour les autos c'est aussi simple que ça
cette personne sur 10 se rendrait plus
souvent au cœur de la métropole si se
déplacer et se stationner était plus
facile selon un sondage commandé par la
Société de développement commercial du
centre-ville on n'aurait jamais 250 000
places de stationnement au centre-ville
même qu'on fasse sauter de Mont-Royal on
pourrait pas en faire autant
arrondissement Ville Marie compte 7000
cases de stationnement tarifié en
bordure de rue mais il y en a des
milliers d'autres dans les
stationnements intérieurs selon Glenn
castanera il faut installer davantage de
panneaux comme ceux-ci pour indiquer où
se trouve ces places et si elles sont
toujours disponibles
peu de gens savent qu'il y a environ 50
000 places de stationnement en rue au
centre-ville qui sont très très peu
utilisés les soirs et les fin de semaine
où sont-ils ces stationnement là et
comment est-ce qu'on y a accès ils sont
un peu partout au centre-ville il y a
des grands stations institutionnels
comme la Place des Arts la Place
Ville-Marie et plusieurs petits
stationnements privés et nous on est
convaincu que la solution passe par la
mutualisation c'est à dire de mettre en
commun tous ces stationnements-là au
sein d'une même plateforme l'agence de
mobilité durable travaille justement à
mettre au point une application pour
faciliter la vie des automobilistes qui
veulent se garer au centre-ville elle
indiquera où ils sont susceptibles de
trouver du stationnement public en
bordure de rue mais aussi dans les
stationnements intérieurs gérés par le
privé elle va permettre d'avoir une
formation à destination sur la
disponibilité du stationnement donc
peut-être pas totalement temps réel mais
avec une bonne information pour les pour
les citoyens les automobilistes elle va
aussi donner une information sur les
stationnements privés donc quand ils
sont disponible comment est-ce qu'on
peut y accéder éventuellement le même
l'occupation mais pour y arriver il
faudra conclure des ententes avec les
propriétaires de ces stationnements et
instauré un système pour partager
l'information ce qui ne sera pas une
main stage la littérature nous dit à peu
près 30 % de la congestion dans les
centres-villes en Amérique du Nord il y
a des gens qui recherchent une place
nationale donc intervenir là-dessus ça
aurait un impact très fort à la fois sur
sur la qualité de vie des gens mais
aussi sur les gaz à effet de serre une
première mouture de l'application
devrait voir le jour en 2024 d'ici là
bien des automobilistes vont continuer
de tourner un rang ici Olivier Bachant
Radio-Canada Montréal